geht es um die impfpflicht denn sie soll
millionen menschen zusätzlich vor corona
schützen doch genau das das bezweifeln
jetzt die top virologen in diesem land
vor allem weil sogar zwei impfungen ja
kaum noch vor ansteckung mit omikron
schützen ist die impfpflicht wegen der
omicron variante also sinnlos unser
großes thema jetzt hier bei
bild.de will nämlich die impfpflicht auf
jeden fall noch durchsetzen komme was
wolle unbedingt der minister der auch in
diesen tagen notfalls selbst impft
gesundheitsminister kalotte bach ja so
ist es er wirbt für die impfpflicht
jetzt auch mit einem satz der noch für
heftige diskussionen
hier sehen wir noch mal das bild vom
selber im von karl lauterbach in diesen
tagen es gerade drei tage all dieses
bild wo er selbst also nochmal zur
spritze zur impfung gegriffen hat ja und
jetzt sorgt er mit einer aussage die ja
für die impfpflicht werben soll für
heftige diskussionen mit dieser
ich glaube dass also erste jeden impfen
sollten denjenigen der geimpft werden
will weil er der im pflicht nachkommt
oder denjenigen der sich impfen lässt
ganz freiwillig es wird ja niemand gegen
seinen willen geimpft selbst die
impfpflicht führte dazu dass man sich
zum schluss freiwillig impfen lässt
selbst die impfpflicht führt dazu dass
sich menschen am ende freiwillig impfen
lassen das ist reine linke sich nicht
alle nicht total spannender satz einsatz
der weiter für diskussionen sorgen wird
und wir diskutieren über diesen und
darüber dass die impfpflicht insgesamt
in frage stellt weil steht weil zweifel
groß werden dass sie gegen die omikron
variante wirklich überhaupt nichts
bringt das sie sinnlos ist darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit einem der omicron
ganz besonders gut kennt und
zugeschaltet ist nämlich professor dr
wolfgang kaiser der derzeit in südafrika
zu romy con variante forscht und uns aus
kapstadt zugeschaltet ist einen schönen
guten tag sie haben die bewohner
mutation data und omikron erlebt sie
forschen an der universität stellen was
zur nikon gibt es aus medizinischer
sicht aus der forschung irgend eine
begründung dafür dass wir jetzt zu
diesem zeitpunkt die impfpflicht in
deutschland noch so schnell wie möglich
einführen sollten
kann ich mich nicht äußern weil das ist
natürlich gesichtspunkte sind mit denen
wir menschen uns nicht aus gelten da
geht's ja um rechtliche ethische und
sonstige dinge und natürlich auch viel
um psychologie
aber eins ist ganz klar und das zeigen
unsere daten
zwar schützt die impfung wie wir sie
jetzt haben nicht vor einer infektion
mit dem omikron virus oder nur zu einem
geringen teil nicht möchte ich zurück
nehmen also nicht sehr gut dagegen aber
sie ist doch sehr gut gegen eine schwere
erkrankung und es haben gerade wiederum
zwei neue studien die wir jetzt dieser
tage als reprint also vorläufige studien
online gestellt haben hier aus kapstadt
gezeigt wir hatten geschaut in der
vierten welle die jetzt zu ende geht bei
uns also wir sind ja deutschland etwa
vier wochen voraus die ausgelöst war
durch auch mikron und haben gesehen dass
diejenigen die geimpft war ein enorm
reduziert das risiko hatten ins
krankenhaus zu müssen sauerstoff zu
brauchen oder an der infektion ganze
versterben und da mache ich mir
natürlich sorgen denn südafrika hat sie
ist ja relativ leicht jetzt in der inter
vierten welle und das liegt daran dass
zwar nur die knappe hälfte der
erwachsenen überhaupt geimpft ist aber
doch sehr viele menschen in dem verlauf
der letzten fast zwei jahren schon eine
komische infektion durchgemacht haben
und dadurch eine gewisse kontinuität
erworben haben der preis ist natürlich
hoch es sind sehr viele menschen auch an
kubicki gestorben das ist natürlich gar
nicht positiv aber die dies überlebt
haben die haben eine gewisse grund
immunität die ebenso wie die impfung vor
einem schweren verlauf schützt und das
ist eigentlich das weswegen ich mir für
deutschland sorgen machen denn sie haben
ja auch noch eine erhebliche lücke dort
und die chance dass diejenigen die jetzt
nicht geimpft sind bereits komitaten und
genesen sind die chance ist sehr gering
und für diese menschen ist auch eine
omikron infektion immer noch potenzial
lebensbedrohend auch wir haben patienten
auf intensivstationen auch wir haben
patienten die an komik versterben die
sind fast alle ungeliebt und ist es aber
so dass die zweifach impfung im grunde
vor ansteckung mit nikon nicht schützt
vor einem schweren verlauf schon aber
vor ansteckung nicht das würde meinen
persönlichen eindruck im moment voll
folgen natürlich kenne ich viel mehr
menschen die geimpft sind als ungeimpft
aber mein eindruck ist im moment dass
sich eben geimpfte sei es ihr bei der
arbeit in der schule bei freunden
reihenweise massenweise anstecken sie
erleben jetzt in deutschland das was wir
durchgemacht haben im dezember inklusive
in meiner eigenen abteilung es ist
unglaublich wie viele menschen sich
infizieren dieses virus ist einfach sehr
ansteckend und
deswegen und das sind durchbruch
infektionen und ich muss auch sagen
selbst bei gebürsteten also denjenigen
die drei impfstoffdosen hatten ist diese
infektion oft nicht ganz so milde also
es ist nicht nur so ein harmloser
kleiner schnupfen sondern die gegen
wirklich einige tage
flach und und fühlen sich richtig krank
also es ist damit ist sicherlich nicht
zu scherzen aber man braucht da nicht
ins krankenhaus man wird nicht wirklich
bedrohlich krank und das ist der große
vorteil
natürlich kann man argumentieren omikron
ist ja nun schon in deutschland breitet
sich rapide aus nützt ist dennoch zu
impfen meine meinung dazu ist klar man
hätte es vorgezogen früher geimpft zu
sagen jetzt vollständig geimpft zu sein
oder gar schon gewusst hat aber etwas
ist immer noch besser als gar nichts
also da muss ich muss ich klar sagen
selbst wenn man es bislang nicht gemacht
hat ist es nie zu spät
anzufangen sich impfen zu lassen
und omikron ist einfach ein sehr
effektives system weniger leute auf
dauer werden entgehen können das sagt
professor dr preise uns zugeschaltete
aus südafrika wo er derzeit an corona
virus vorstadt ist man uns schon vier
wochen weiter und jetzt sehen sie im
bild klaus stöhr der virologe auch mit
ihm wollen wir natürlich sprechen was
eine impfpflicht jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt überhaupt noch bringen könnte
wir fragen uns macht das überhaupt noch
sinn immer mehr geimpfte sind infiziert
oder infizieren sich und immer mehr
virologen sagen so richtig hilft das
buch dann auch nicht mehr gegen omikron
kannst du ein bisschen absprechen aber
infiziert werden viele dann dennoch also
die frage was kann das überhaupt noch
bringen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt sollte
man es überhaupt schaffen sich da
irgendwie auf den viel zu einigen
also zuerst müssen wir mal feststellen
dass in deutschland noch vielleicht 32
millionen über 60 nicht geimpften und
die sind diejenigen die wirklich auch
schwer erkranken da breitet sich einfach
erzählt die jüngsten können sich
infizieren aber in aller regel verläuft
das einigermaßen okay man muss nicht
mehr ans krankenhaus welt ein kommt
dabei wird man nicht in der pflicht ich
aber es gibt eben noch viele die nicht
geimpft sind oder vielleicht auch nicht
gewusst hat und die würden von der
impfung definitiv profitieren das ist ja
das was man mit der impfpflicht
vielleicht erreichen würde aber die
frage ist ja gibt alternativen zur
impfpflicht dass das erste um diese
hörer im phase zu erreichen hat man
diese alternativen schon ausgeschöpft
und das zweite ist eine logistisch
zeitliche frage wie schafft man es noch
jetzt vor dem beginn des sommers die wo
der infektionsdruck sich um 10 bis 15
verringert schafft man das noch irgend
auch eine signifikante anzahl von
menschen die dich haben ohne impfpflicht
halt nicht impfen lassen auch noch dann
zu erreichen und das ist eben die
kritische frage mit biologisch ist es
eigentlich vernünftig die impfpflicht zu
evaluieren aber gemeinsam mit den
anderen möglichkeiten die im phase zu
erhöhen und dann gemeinsam nutzen kosten
abzuwägen nutzen risiko abzuwägen und
dann zu denen ob die impfpflicht
tatsächlich das richtig ist man müsste
ja auch noch überlegen neben der
allgemeinen im pflegt wenn man ja auch
die
mit einer impfpflicht die eine besonders
hohe krankheit war die 50 bis 60 auch da
hat er ja noch in der diskussion
ausgelöst auch das ist ja noch in der
diskussion herr stöhr jetzt haben sie
diese fragen gestellt und damit schon
impliziert dass das natürlich verdammt
schwierig ist wenn das auch gleich in
der theorie noch ganz sinnvoll klingt
das in der praxis dann auch umzusetzen
das ist ja das problem also wir kriegen
es doch in der zeit gar nicht mehr
gebacken und wir wissen gar nicht mit
welchem impfstoff weil eben die
zweitimpfung wenn wir auf die ansteckung
schauen im grunde keinen unterschied
macht gegenüber der 0 im funk das heißt
dann gibt es für die impfpflicht kein
keinen tatsächlichen sinn
genau also dass alle diese mittel
theologische frage man darf nicht
irgendwie mit methode jetzt favorisieren
ohne die anderen nicht angeschaut zu
haben und die beste herauszufinden die
zweite frage ist ja was könnte man als
alternative dann noch von der
biologischen seite dann sich überlegen
und hier sehen ja genau das was er
breiter verschrieben hat das wird ja
auch nicht nur in deutschland passieren
passiert der ist in dänemark in england
so dass ich sehr sehr viele menschen
infizieren werden die natürliche
immunität vor dem ziel in kürze noch
nicht kennt ist jetzt dass die nur
eigentlich die natürliche immunität auf
getrotzt und darauf dass die
existierenden
immunität durch die impfstoffe zu dieser
lang anhaltenden und breiten die
mobilität führen wird die impfung allein
bringt das ende der party nächten zögert
die infektion mit jeder die macht die
infektion für diese lägen diese jahr
bekommen werden das sind alle viel viel
weniger konsequent
das scheine was man sich überlegen
mussten ja und dann nicht abwendbar
infektion oder erstinfektion somit wie
möglich zu gestalten das ist das erste
mal irgendwo panel das ist so weit so
möglichkeit gibt und deswegen ist die
impfung bleibt die impfung wichtig aber
die impfpflicht jetzt ist meines
erachtens ein verschenktes tool man
hätte das eher überlegen können man weiß
ja wie eine pandemie ende und wenn die
endet dann ist die impfung da diesmal
und dann weiß auch dass eine impfung
niemals alle menschen in der bevölkerung
erreichen werden sind dicke bücher
darüber geschrieben worden
unterschiedliche regionen
unterschiedliche länder damals hätte man
alles vorher sagen können alles wieder
bis zum schluss verschieben die gesamte
diskussion wir hören gerade was noch
wichtiger ist als corona wie höheren
irgendwo im hintergrund ihr baby 2 bei
ihm ist nicht mein leben wir wissen es
gerade nicht falls es wichtigeres gibt
noch wichtiger sind diese moment als
corona als eine impfpflicht und als bild
live dann einfach gerne kurz rausgehen
und helfen
herr professor preise lassen sie uns
einmal in die zukunft starten sie sind
derzeit in südafrika forschen dort sind
uns vier wochen voraus mit dieser
erkenntnis mit diesem vorwissen wie ist
ihre prognose für die nächsten vier
wochen in deutschland wo wird
deutschland in vier wochen stehen ja sie
leben jetzt wirklich die einfach die
auswirkungen von enorm hohen
infektionszahlen ich habe mitbekommen
dass die laborkapazitäten jetzt
ausgereizt ist auch in deutschland das
kann man sagen war kam zugeklappt das
hatten wir ja auch schon öfter ist wo
man sich jetzt behelfen muss kann man
mit antiken schnelltests oder gar
verzicht auf testung jetzt weitermachen
das sind alles alles probleme und ja vor
denen man auch im 21 jahrhundert noch
steht das ist interessant ist auch eine
industriegesellschaft dann irgendwo an
ihre grenzen stößt
also ich denke deutschland hört sich
wird sich auf eine hohe zahl von
infektionen
gefasst machen müssen ob es gelingt die
risikogruppen die nicht geimpft sind und
man darf ja auch nie vergessen es gibt
immer noch natürliche personen die zwar
geimpft sind aber bei denen die impfung
aus biologischen gründen nicht optimal
an stellt also zb ältere oder
immungeschwächte
ob es gelingt diese personengruppen zu
bewahren vor einer infektion ist
sicherlich eine ganz große
herausforderung und ich sehe schon auch
dann wieder mehr patienten in
krankenhäusern und ja sicherlich auch in
intensivstationen
hier in südafrika sind sind wir
natürlich sehr erleichtert wir hatten am
anfang wir machen hier das erste land
welches omikron hatte hat mir das
schlimmste befürchtet als wir sagen wie
er anstecken das ist wie viele
infektionen aufgetreten sind und hatten
uns auf eine schreckliche weihnachtszeit
vorbereitet er aber zum glück ist uns
das erspart geblieben wie gesagt das
deutet gar nicht dass nicht auch heute
noch an omikron patienten natürlich
versterben aber es sind halt viel
weniger als sie befürchtet hatten aber
das liegt eben an den besonderen
voraussetzungen
wir sind natürlich auch mitten im
hochsommer die bevölkerung sind steht
viel jünger als in europa wir hatten
auch die großen schulferien die jetzt
erst ende gehen also wir hatten ja schon
einige voraussetzungen
günstiger aussehen als in deutschland
aber was mir wirklich sorgen bereitet
ist das einfach noch erhebliche anteile
der risiko gruppen noch nicht geimpft
sind in deutschland nicht glaube diese
personen müssen jetzt wirklich alles
daran setzen sich nicht zu infizieren
und so schnell es eben geht riefen zu
lassen das ist die botschaft aus
südafrika von professor preiser der uns
einen ganzen schritt voraus ist dort im
jahr erste mikron land sozusagen
erforscht mit und an omikron herzlichen
dank dass sie heute früh bei bild live
an ganz kurze frage ja oder nein bei
herrn stören noch einmal den test
gemacht der gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach sagt bei einer impfpflicht
ist ja immer noch die impfung freiwillig
sehen sie das auch so ist das dann noch
eine freiwillige impfung wenn es eine
impfpflicht gibt
ja da kann ich nur als bürger und aber
nicht als als bürger antworten als
zuschauer für mich passt das nicht
zusammen mit pflicht ist nichts
freiwillige danke ihnen für diese
einordnung das nämlich sehen ganz viele
zuschauer so und es geht um genau diese
aussage vom bundesgesundheitsminister
vom abend danke ihnen für das gespräch
genommen diese aussage geht es denn die
schauen wir jetzt noch einmal rein die
impfpflicht die der mehrere dazu bringen
soll sich freiwillig impfen zu lassen
ich glaube dass also ärzte jeden impfen
sollten denjenigen der geimpft werden
will weil er der im pflicht nachkommt
oder denjenigen der sich impfen das ganz
freiwillig es wird ja niemand gegen
seinen willen geimpft selbst die
impfpflicht führte dazu dass man sich
das beschlussreif freiwillig impfen
lässt er gut da hat vielleicht eine oder
andere ein paar verständnisprobleme auf
jeden fall müssen wir über diesen satz
sprechen die impfpflicht sie ist einfach
gerade der aufreger im land und tausende
menschen geht auch immer wieder auf die
strasse julius filme ist jetzt bei uns
vor dir aufgeschlagen du bist dass
unsere politik ressort ist eine ganze
seite heute in der bild zeitung die sich
genau auf diesem thema widmet die
impfpflicht aber lasst uns über den satz
des gesundheitsministers sprechen die
dann viele freiwillig dazu bringen soll
sich impfen zu lassen was glaubst du was
löst das aus wie bewertest du das ich
würde sagen dass unser
gesundheitsminister ja einfach nur fort
was bisher in der kommunikation
losgetreten hat an vielen stellen haben
wir versucht menschen zur impfung zu
pushen matching nennt man das im
englischen mit kleinen hindernissen im
alltag wir kennen das alle der gang ins
restaurant 2 geht dann war irgendwann
auch der test notwendig leute die sich
nicht impfen lassen krank werden
quarantäne müssen bekommen keinen lohn
mehr vom arbeitgeber das sind alles
schwächere oder härtere maßnahmen die
menschen zur impfung zu bewegen schon da
haben wir hier bei bild oft gesagt es
ist doch die impfpflicht durch die
hintertür und jetzt zu behaupten wenn
die offiziellen pflicht kommt und nicht
mehr nur alltags nachteile bis hin zur
richtigen isolation sondern sogar
bußgelder kommen im notfall wenn ich das
muss wird nicht bezahlen möchte sogar
eine
vollstreckungshaftbefehl einer
freiwilligen impfung zu sprechen das ist
schon wirklich da muss man wirklich sehr
sehr sehr viel fantasie haben nur weil
ich das militär durch die straßen fährt
und die menschen mit einem gewehr in den
hintern schießt damit endlich der
impfstoff im körper ist also diese
diskussion sorgt für heftige
diskussionen
sagt uns einmal noch den zeitplan für
den bundestag also die impfpflicht die
kam später überhaupt auf den tisch als
angekündigt hier war es bei bild live im
gespräch mit paul ronzheimer als der
damals noch nicht ganz kanzler olaf
scholz das angekündigt hat als stellung
bezogen hat sich positioniert hat gesagt
hat auch ich bin für eine impfpflicht
die werte ich aus dem bundestag heraus
noch in diesem jahr auf den weg bringen
noch 20 21 das hat nicht funktioniert
jetzt haben wir mitte richtung ende
januar schon wann kommt das im bundestag
auf den tisch ja das ist tatsächlich ein
problem was sich viele leute fragen die
debatte ist jetzt sechs oder acht wochen
alt und seither ist einfach nichts
passiert es gibt nichts konkret dass man
weiß nicht wer wird geimpft wie oft muss
ich geimpft werden es ist ja nicht ganz
klar gilt die vorstände die impfung gilt
der booster gibt es eine vierte impfung
die möglicherweise in frage kommt muss
ist der omnicom stoff sein wer macht
eine beratung wenn menschen resistente
und wer setzt am ende strafen durch
welche strafen gibt es all diese fragen
seien offen es gibt keine konkreten
anträge einen einzigen aus der fdp wo es
darum geht die menschen ab 50 nur zu
impfen aber wann das ganze umgesetzt
werden könnte total offen und wir sehen
ja die debatte wandert dahin zu sagen
löst uns omikron das problem selbst der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der fdp
johannes vogel hat schon einem interview
gesagt möglicherweise löst und das
problem selbst der chef der stiko einer
der der meisten weißem stoff in
deutschland thomas merten seite
stuttgart schon gesagt ich bin gegen
eine impfpflicht spaltet die
gesellschaft wir sehen ist jede woche 70
80 tausend menschen auf der strasse
gegen ebendiese impfpflicht auf die
straße geht demonstrieren und all diese
probleme all diese diskussion um diese
spaltung löst ja am ende auch aus dass
sogar die kassenärzte sagen wir impfen
jeden der hier freiwillig vorbeikommt
sehr sehr gern und helfen bei allen mit
aber wir wollen wirklich nicht der
vollstrecker von staatlichen maßnahmen
seien also am ende bleibt die frage bei
all der diskussion wie soll es überhaupt
umgesetzt werden und wurde war das könne
man glaube ich bei alt ist diskussion
problem fragestellungen hindernissen
zuspitzen die impfpflicht ist so gut wie
tot ja und omikron war die erklärung für
den wortbruch dass man nämlich von der
ablehnung der impfpflicht zu einer
befürwortung der im flick gekommen ist
und dasselbe omikron wird jetzt
voraussichtlich die erklärung sein dafür
dass es mit der umsetzung nicht
funktioniert mit der umsetzung der
impfpflicht danke julius böhm unser bild
reporter hier im studio